ONE DRJILL DRONES ON ABOUT HOW
E TILL ISONE.
PRESIDENT'S AGENDAPPOSED BYALL S
BECAUSE THE ANALYSTF WHA THEY
DIDN'T SEEOMING IS LONGER THAN
ONE OF FOO JOE ENJOYS COMING.
SCREW YOU, DR. SEUSS.
NEW SHERIFF IN TOWN.
THIS WEEK, FIRST LADY, PROFEOR
AND PEDIATRIC NEUSURGEON,
. JILL BIDEN.I'M TRYING.
SHE WHINED THAT THE SLOW
PROGRESS OF A HUSBAND POLITICAL
AGENDA IS DUE TO UNEXPECD
PROBLEMS AT ME AND OVERSEAS.
DURING ARIVATE FD-RAISER, MY
INVITE MUST HAVE GOT LOST IN THE
MAIL, DR. LL LAMENTED T
PRESIDENT HAS SO MANY HES AND
PLANS FOR THINGS TH WANTED TO
DO, BUT EVERY TIME I TNED
AROUND, HE HAD TO ASSESS E
PROBLEMS OF THE MENT.
THE AT I DID THE?
I SURE DIDN'T HE SAID THAT.
HE JUST HAS SOANY THINGS
THROWN HIS WAY.
79 YEAR OLD NOTAVING HIS PLANS
COME TRUE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THOSE PLANS
INUDE DON'T GO ITHE BATHTUB.
BUT WE GET IT.
NOT LIKE PRESINTS ARE SUPPOSED
TO ANTICIPATE THING OR RISE TOTR
FAS WHEN THEY RUN THE FREE
WORLD.
INSTD,ORMAL PRESIDENT SHOULD
NEVER EXPECT ARISIS.
HE SHOULD JUST CRUISE ALONG ON A
BOMBER JACKETND AVIATOR
SUNGLASS.
KNOWIN HIS VP HAS GOT
EVYTHING COVERED.
RIGHT, KAM?
IF ONLY WEADOME NEW, LOCK
LINGUINE COMPLETWITH BONGOS.
>> Vice President Hais: I DO
BELIEVE THAT W-- WE CERTAINLY
BELIEVE THA--E SHOULD JUST
SETTLE.
>> CLEAR WERE NOT.
>> Vice esident Harris: AND
AT'S WHY I DO BELIE THAT WE
ARE LIVING IN AN UNSETED TI
TIMES.
>> Greg: PERFE.
MEWHILE -- ONLY HERE, SATURDAY
DURING A TRITO THE MID
MIDDLE EAST, JOEAS STUMBLING
TO IT AS USU.
>> Preside Biden: YOU'VE
HEARD ME SAY BEFORE ITHE
WESTERN MOUAINS, AND GLOBAL
INITIATIVES, GLOBAL
FRASTRUCTURE --S THIS
CONSISTENTITH WIT WHO WE ARE?
THE QUESTNS SOMETIMES SAY WHAT
I MEAN.
I JUS ANSWER THE QUESTION
I DON'T FORGET ANYTHING I SAID.
STEPHEBIEGUN THING HE
REMEMBERTHAT IT MADE SENSE TO
ME.
WHAT SAY YOU, JOE?
>> SHE'S A DOCTOR.
SHE IS RIG.
HOW AM I SUPPOSED TO GET
ANYTHING DON WITH ALL THE
THINGS HAPPENING?
MAKE PRIS GO DOWN, BUT THEY
ARE GOING UP.
IT'S THE OPPOSIT MAN.
GET E GLOBA WARMING THING
HAPPENING, BUT IT'S TOO H.
YOU OUGHT.
JAILR JUST MARRIED AND
FLECK?
WHSAW THATOMING?I THOUGHT HE WAO
MATT DON?
>> Greg:E WOULD BE AREAT
PRESIDENT IF NOTHI WAS
HAPPENING.
>>HEY KP SAYING TS.
REMEMBER, BIDEN OBSERVEDT THE23Y
PELE CAPTURING STUFF ON MY
DESK
YOU'RE THE PREDENT.
IF THEREASOTHING, WE
ULDN'T ND ONE.
THATAS CRAZY, I HADN'T SEEN
THAT BEFE, THE SPEECH WHERE HE
WA JUST LIKE YOU'VEEARD ME
SAY BEFORE THAT HE S MADE A
POINT OF NOISES.
I THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO -- FOR
A MINUTE THERE, THAT WAS CRAZY.
WHEN I HEARD HE WAS ON A
FOUR-DAY TRIP, IAS LIKE HOW
LONG WAS THAT?
>> Greg:HAT WAS GOOD.
THAT WAS GOOD
I LOVE HOW THESELL THESE
PEOPLE ARE GOING ON.
CRIME AND WAR
SPEAK OF THE FEW TIMES HE CAME
OUT OF THEELLAR, HE TOLD US
THAT HE HAD YEARS AND YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE.
THAT HE H SEEN EVERYTHING YOU
COULD POSSIBLY THINK OF
EXPT --
>> Greg: EVERYTHIN
>> EVERYING YOU COULD POSSIBLY
THINK OF.
SOMEBO SAID THE BL FAILED IN
ITS JUST A BIG OLD BUCKET OF
GRUEL.
>> Greg: NOT GOI TO SAY IT.
NOT GOING TO SAY.
KAT, I THINK THEROBLEM WITH
BIDENS THAT HE WASN'T SUPPOSED
TO WORK.EVERYTHING WAS SUPPOSEDO
BACK TO NORMAL.ONCE COMPLETE,VES
GOG TO SMOOTH OUT.
NOW, THE WORLDOESN'T CATER TO
PELE WHO -- I DON KNOW THEENDF T
OUT OKAY.
>> Greg: THANK Y.
>> THAT WAS GREAT.
I ACTUALLY DON'T THINK THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEESURPRISED.
WHAT SHE IS SANG IS TY DID
AL THE STUFF TT HE WANTEDO
DO, B IT'S THE OTHER STUFF
KES HAPPENING.THINK PRETTY WL ED
THAT THE PRESIDEY IS A
FAST-PACED WORK ENVIRONMENT
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
YOU HAVE T DEAL WITH THINGS AS
THEY COME UP.
YOU'RE THE PRESIDENT.
>> Gre IEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING, JUDGE, WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING IS THEY WHICH TRE WERE
TWO PRESIDENT.
THE ONE THAT WALKED AROUND,
SHAKING HANDS.
JOB JUST WANT TO BE THE
VICE PREDENT AND ON ANY DEVICE L
PRESIDENT WHO SHOULD
REPUBLICAN.
DONE.
I KNOW!
JUDGE, I SWEAR I GET MORE
APPLAUSE
TRY THAT ON "THE FIVE."
>> YEAH, I WILLRY THA.
HERE'S THE THING WITHER.
SHE IS AS DUMB ASE I
SHE BECSE WE NEVER EXPECTED
ROE VS. WADE AND 90 THINK ABOUT
IT AND SHE IS LIKE NO, WAIT, WE
DIDN'T BELIEVE IT.AND THEN SHE R
PECTED IT.
ALL THESE THINGS HAPN.
THEY WERBUILDING UP FOR MONTHS
AND MONTHS, AND THE RT JOE FOR
APONS.
TH DID N WAS COMIN
WE HAV 13 -- WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT IT.
E D YOU WALKED IN, Y KNEW
WHAT ARE TALKING AUT?
YOU'RE LYING, THAT'S ALL
>> Greg: HE'S NEVEREEN RIGHT
ON ANYTHING.
>> HE'S NEVER BEEN RIGHTN ANY
CORE POLICY ISSUE EVER.
>> Greg: BUT YOU KW EYE IS
ALWAYS HAPPY?
BECAUSE 'S ETERNALLY SURPRISED
BY THE NEXT MOMENT INIME.
>> IHINK IT WOULD HAVE BEE
BEER SERVED IF WE WOULD HAVE
RAN FOR WALMARTREETER.
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMETHING NE
COMING IN.
EVENTULY, SOMEONE IS GOINGO
FIND THE HANDSHAKE STAND IN
FRONT OF THE DOOR.
>> Greg: DOWNHE CORN POP
STORY.
THEYON'T HAVE A CHOICE WHEN
THEY AREN LE TRYING T BUY
THE --
>> HE WOU STAND RIGHT IN FRONTO
GO THROU HIM, ANDHEN HAVE TO
MOVE BACK.
>> AND THEN YOUOULD A A
QUESTION WHAT IL IS SO-AND-SO.
WHAT ARE YOU ASKING ME R?
ISHIS MY JOB?>> Greg: NOT MY JO.
TWO PRESIDENT.
WE SHOULD GET A REAL PRESENT
THAT IS REPUBLICAN AND THETHE
GUY THAT IS GOOD AT PLAYIN A
PRESIDENT, THE DEMOCRAT.THE DEM.
THE BILL CLINTON, THE
BARACK OMA IN THE
BEHIND-THE-SCENES, YOU GOT THE
MECHANIC I GOT DALD TRUMP
DOING ALL THE WEIRD STUFF.
I KE HOW THE WENT TO JAMIE
NOING.